john hines shaved his head yeah I see
him yeah if you want to if you can
handle it
it's really disturbing yeah completely
see what I saw you had more of a shaved
head and I did a number one all around I
figured it's summer why not I'll give it
a shot and then I did it and then
they're saying like it did I like it
no I was kind of freaked out by it
honestly I was freaked out but yeah you
look like a skinhead
I mean Gary's such a weirdo he's on the
wrap-up show with John and he goes hey
you know if you should go ahead I'll
shave my head solidarity he like
volunteers these weird things like why
would he wanna shave need that uh it was
weird because I was talking about doing
it and then Rahsaan is less on the show
was saying I've [ __ ] I'll shave your
head I'll shave my head with you like -
but he can't attend to it right and then
Gary said yeah I'll do it - and he goes
what the [ __ ] all shave my head that's
what he's Bobby wants to be in on it I
know and then all of a sudden he backed
off because he says what did I just
promise on anything going out yes I will
volunteer myself and Gary we will shave
our heads in solidarity I would do that
I do that I'll tell you what yes if you
shaved your head I would totally go
there with you I give it a shot with the
phone why would he even say that you
weren't looking for anyone to shave
their head it was a nice gesture
you want people you change your
hairstyle do you need solid a like I go
for a haircut Gary this is hell I'm
gonna get a haircut - that starts when
when when a kid is in chemo and they
lose their hair you go you know what I'm
gonna be in solidarity with you were
elected what happened was we had spent
20 not me really Rahsaan is the one
driving this train Rahsaan spent 20
minutes of the show
begging Jon to shave his head John
didn't want to do it yeah but why would
you care I didn't rasaan said hey Gary
why would you say I did then I changed
my mind almost immediately but why would
you even volunteer that you're gonna
shave your head well how does it
matter to him Wow he's a weirdo God very
weird
you are I think they both really wanted
me to do it since john was dying of
cancer and he had chemo I am gonna lose
his hair but you don't do that for a
friend with male pattern baldness and
carry sounds all excited he's like
that's it I'm only like where did that
excitement come from I said that on the
show they said I'm not a cancer victim
here right you know I appreciate the
gesture but then I mean Gary was kind of
baiting me into doing it then I turn
around it was I'm not saying it wasn't
but then her son's done it before when
you said it then I as a host immediately
flipped it was like wait a minute that
Gary's gonna shave his head they're like
why he has a full head of hair why would
you do that the Bagheri you did say you
would do it because it'll grow back yeah
I mean it sounded funny for a second for
me I would shave my head how good it's
gonna grow back but using that line why
does he draw and get giant caps up on
his teeth so that he with you yeah I'll
shave my head if you get big giant cap
it's the craziest logic I ever heard
I always think it'll piss on my nipples
while you then Jonel out it's gonna
shave his head in solidarity with John
I'm and John's hair is gonna grow back I
mean it's just weird
I wish Gary would shave his head I'm why
I don't know but all right Johnny good
luck with that look man thank you I mean
you're back to I like your look right
now no I will keep it at this life at
least try to you're good you want to hit
him with the hind song or no I love it
hit him with the hind song sometimes
where my life gets boring I think about
John
I hit him with the
[Music]
got you
you